[Music]
hey welcome back to the Wolfram tech
conference 2018 if you haven't tuned in
before I'm just I'm here talking with
various developers another interesting
people who are using what from
technology and release aways I'm here
with Tom Wickham Jones can you tell us a
little bit about what you do here at
will from maybe how long you've been
here and what you're doing talking about
here at the conference specifically yeah
sure fine so I've been with the company
kind of a long time almost since the
very beginning not the beginning but I
joined a couple of years after after it
started and I've been working on various
the Wolfram engine the main core
computational technology I am
particularly interested in computer
languages and implement implementation
of computer languages and I've worked on
many different projects ideas from other
other places you see what role they have
benefits they might have and seeing what
role they have one of the core things
that involves is the notion of code
compilation compilation of code means
look in Wikipedia but it says he would
say a compiler is a system for
translating one form of a language
into another language quite often you
use a compiler to turn a high-level
represent
into a much lower level language it's
closer to the way that actual hardware
works but there's many other interests
so I've worked with languages had a
compiler for many many years in the last
few years we've been working on a
totally new version of the compiler
rebuild starting from scratch using the
latest knowledge and you know advances
in languages to build a whole new
compiler technology and we've been
working on it for you know about three
years and conferences like this I've
been giving you know showing people
previews of where the technology is
going but this year is different because
we're actually including the first you
know initial version of 12 anyway so um
and that's that's pretty exciting
software developer it's kind of cool
because you you work on things for a
long time but the real the time when you
feel really great if it's when
the fruit of your labor gets included in
an actual actual release and people
start using it usually what you find is
they're using it in all sorts of ways
that you never never imagined you know
your way of thinking about it so that's
that's that that's pretty exciting it's
also neat because we've it started out
with working together but we built up a
big team and quite a lot of our team
we've been giving different so I think
that's um that's that's that's what I've
been doing for the past so other members
of the team what sort of talks are they
giving here well they're using the
technology compiler focus on the
compiler is to make programming
efficient and leverage new ways of
reaching new types of programs that have
been maybe a bit harder to write or
reaching down to sort of machine
hardware or special exotic hardware
things like GPUs and suchlike and our
compiler technology is an interesting
way to so be people showing for you
it's coding so not everybody wants to
coding but quite a lot of people do as
well and so it's a it's a component of
the language I know is it is the compile
function as it has been well it's a
whole new technology that comes out with
it so it's um it uses a an underlying
compiler tools that are used more
traditional languages and that's kind of
YUM so we
do you sort of processing on the code
and then we talk we translate into the
LLVM representation and that that's
that's very beneficial because there's
also things that support LLVM and then
we could that we can leverage those
technologies to translate out and get
fast efficient for a you know wide
variety of different sort of hardware
including all the platforms that we want
to run and other platforms that we don't
so you know a lot of potential you know
new areas so you mentioned that I mean
you're excited to see users kind of take
this so what are some potential
applications that you would hope that
users well I mean I think this is
there's you know there's a variety of
different things that it that it can do
I think people that just want to do
large-scale computation high-performance
computation and there's a lot of people
you know in the you know users that you
know they do interesting computations
but they just want to take it further
and utilizing more aspects you know
multi-core
you know just just access that people
haven't really haven't really had before
another aspect that's kind of
interesting is people inside the company
can build features on top of there's
lots of opportunities for that for
example one area that's kind of
interesting is the network functionality
that we have and I've been working with
them that they're pretty excited to
start incorporating some of the
technologies you know that our compiler
can do and in essence you know just
trying to put a simple statement on this
the code that we're you know when when
code is processed with with our compiler
we're taking off language code and it
can execute as fastest you know in more
traditional or C or C++ code because
it's usually the same same suite of
technologies and that's you know we're
pretty interested that's that's pretty
exciting but you get a lot of the
benefits so it's it's kind of a win in
both you don't have to work at some very
low level but
yeah so you do you see the Wolfram
compiler technology being used to push
code into production settings oh yeah
very much so
another interesting aspect of it is
being able to make standalone
applications that can execute so you
could develop something in the
infrastructure but generate a standalone
library or something or a standalone
application that could execute you know
without without having to you know
you know I think you've gone through all
of them beyond do you have anything else
you want to share with that's an
interesting question
so I mean I think I've I think it's you
know it's a way of you know sort of
introducing you know languages evolve
over time rapidly in the languages that
people are interested in now you know
might not existed a few years ago and I
think our compiler technology is is also
you know very new interesting sort of
you know so I think people are
interested in languages I think it's
worth taking a look at what we're
putting together lots of interesting
features so compiler you know compiler
technologies theory of computer science
a lot of computer science departments
know not all of you know they devote
this time to projects based around
compilers and what we've been working on
is is you know it's a nice open
infrastructure it's entirely implemented
in the Wolfram language which has been
kind of you know an interesting exercise
in itself to build something really big
in our own language of course now we're
working on this we have a compiler we're
working on trying to compile high load
so that's that's that's a typical thing
that compilers and that's that's that's
that's kind of one interesting aspect of
the compiler that we've worked on is
that it supports so it's it has static
typing so so we and we have a nice type
inferencing system that we've developed
that's we put a lot of work into our
type inferencing system and this is
using very much the sort of latest
knowledge end
you know sort of state-of-the-art
inferencing technologies they're
important because you need you you don't
need to put you know in old type
languages you just very cumbersome and
if you changed one thing and it was an
impediment because if you wanted to
change your program you had lots of
things we type inferencing you just need
to mark up a few places typically the
input to a function and then everything
else can be gets figured out by the
inferencing engine which is which is
kind of interesting it also supports the
style of programming that's quite
gaining popularity
and that's what's known as it's
polymorphism so you have one version of
the program works in many different ways
but we support a version it's called
parametric polymorphism when you give
type parameters and the use the value of
that is that one bit of code gets used
in many many different in different
places so you don't need to write a lot
of code but you get all the benefits is
that sort of the same I mean I know with
Wolfram language functions generally yes
but that's a more of sort of runtime
type of thing this is doing it at some
sort of ahead of time this is doing
something now assess of the program
before it starts executing and so it's
able to find inconsistencies and
problems and verifications at at some
sort of analysis phase there are pros
and cons that some some things are not
decidable or you know it can be it can
be you know some people that program you
know they like very freeform aspects
things together result coming up on the
other hand sometimes it's good when you
are starting to build some production
code you want a little bit more
assistance and and you might want it to
some some of the benefits
yes there is some sort of analogies so I
guess just one other question ten years
like from now where do you see like um I
would we've got like a huge suite of
plans and projects and things that we
want to we want to work on it has a
tremendous capacity we've just made a
neutral version with a few functions
that people can execute it start to use
but I think it has a lot of potential
for new starter programs it has a lot to
offer the Wolfram system itself so we
can go back into the existing features
and we thank you what to do yeah well
thanks for your talking with me Tom and
if you stick around later after a short
break we're gonna talk to some more
developers thanks for joining
okay cheers everyone
[Music]